I first became aware of John Kennedy as a
kid in India i was growing up in the nineteen
sixties in India
and Kennedy burst onto the Indian imagination
as this powerful energetic charismatic figure
uh... really the first American president
to a done so of for modern india
uh... i remember we had an LP of his inaugural
address i think it had a couple of other speeches
as well
uh... and we would play at home and we would
listen to it i don't think i understood a word
i mean in a deeper sense of what it meant
uh... but
it's under grand and uplifting uh... and over
the years i think Kennedy remained for many
many
decades
the only American president
who captured the imagination
off people outside of America certainly
this was true in India
he captured the imagination of India
he captured the imagination indians he appealed
to Indians
uh... at that level of the heart not just
the level of the head